à karim hakiki c'est très important tout
au long de cette cette séquence à aucun
moment emmanuel macron employer le mot
retrait un retrait la force barkan il a
même été interrogé par la presse sur
cette question l'idée c'est donc on
redéploie les forces ne sais pas
vraiment comment ni à quel niveau les
contours restent flous et au cours de
cette conférence de presse on a bien
compris les éléments de langage du
président de la république était un gros
déploiement des forces non pas
françaises seulement française mais
européenne dans un cadre européen et
africain à la différence de ce qui se
passe au mali le président de la
république n'a pas repris ce mot là il a
il a parlé de redéploiement par exemple
pour les délais de départ aidé des bases
au nord-mali un calendrier floue entre
quatre à six mois at il dit il n'a pas
précisé les questions sécuritaires
comment va se faire ce redéploiement car
la route est long d'un contre le nord
mali et le niger pour l'instant on n'a
pas eu les contours de cette de ce
redéploiement et puis le président de la
république a beaucoup insisté également
sur la présence européenne dans la lutte
anti terrorisme dans la région sénat
région immense le sahel c'est un grand
désert de sable eh bien la france pour
cette fois at il dit on va basculer du
processus barkan vers un processus
dacumba d'acrobates et maintenu dans la
région mais la france ne souhaite plus
intervenir seul dans la région elle sera
accompagnée par les forces spéciales
notamment européennes également
africaine qui seront plus impliqués et
jean termina le président de la
république a même souhaité impliquer
davantage les populations civiles dont
la lutte contre le terrorisme je me
tourne vers vous